[Music]
I'm really excited about season 38 of
course because I have a chance to be
here with you and see it all as it kicks
off
you saw the marooning this morning I did
it was amazing fun what is that like
when you see all of these new people
with sparkles in their eyes well you
know I think you can relate on Big
Brother when you start a new season and
you feel the energy of the people who
are gonna play and you're reminded
that's right they gave up this period of
their time they left their families and
their jobs they want to do this and it
invigorates you and you you're reminded
I want to do it with you and for you and
next you and I want to watch and so
that's the feeling I have when we're out
on this giant boat and we have a group
of people who've left their entire lives
behind to play survivor I feel that same
energy and the responsibility to help
deliver on the promise of an adventure
that will forever change your life
that's why we stay so young chef Dean
was at it it's that it's that life that
we keep getting a life for us from these
people who are excited about this new
because when I was at your 70th birthday
I remember 10 years ago right I remember
you know thinking I was so shocked but
you're right ok so tell me about this
theme the edge of extinction what a name
the edge of extinction idea is really
centered around trying to go deeper
emotionally and spiritually with why
these people want this adventure why do
kids when they're 8 9 10 watch every
week and say I could do that there's
something in us we still want to be
tested even though we live in a
technological world and we're always
involved there's still something about
having your bare feet in the grass in
the sand saying I'm going to climb that
tree people aren't doing that as much
but it's still in us and so the premise
is you're voted out and what you don't
know and nobody knows is that as you
walk off tribal council and turn the
corner you're gonna see a torch and a
little sign post and the signpost says
you have a decision to make if you've
had enough follow the path and your
adventure is over but if you want a
chance to get back in the game grab the
torch and get in the boat and that's all
you know
grab the torch and get in the boat so
our hunch is a lot of people are gonna
say okay I want to play some more but
they have no idea what will be required
of them so they've taken the first step
into the unknown you already left a very
difficult game called survivor you got
voted out this is gonna take you deeper
with only a shot to get back in no
guarantee and when they arrive at
extinction Island in the pitch black
with a single torch
they'll the first person there will
literally arrive to an abandoned island
and a simple sign that says welcome to
extinction Island where you're gonna
work your ass off and if it ever becomes
too much raise the sail that is on the
mast
and a boat will come get you so the only
thing on the island is this old ship's
mast that has a sail and there's a sign
and it says welcome to extinction Island
nothing will be easy when fear and
loneliness set in you'll have to find
the resolve to overcome and if it
becomes too much raise the sail and a
boat will come pick you up in other
words you can quit if you want and the
first person will wake up in the morning
ago what do I do and there will be no
one to tell them to do anything and
maybe a second person will come maybe
everybody will come we don't know what's
going to happen I am getting goosebumps
really yeah good that's wild
again you you you don't cease to amaze
me this team because to keep coming back
and you keep coming up with these fresh
ideas and and to take risks that's
that's what every TV producer wants
that's what every TV viewer at home
wants truly
you